number one one of the things that
happened in in Kyoto was was some people
felt that this 18-year string that
started with with Rio with the earth day
summit in rio that we'd sort of played
out the string and and what came out of
Kyoto was what was called a basic
agreement which was which was with the
United States India China Brazil and
South Africa right and those those those
five sort of separated themselves and
said let's let's let's let's us talk
let's take this offline and wilt and
we'll talk and Mark the question I want
to ask you and then I want to get to the
market mechanisms that seem to be
somewhere between this future and
actually achieving it the question I
want to ask you is is does the UN
Framework still have life in it should
we actually just say that was then it's
this is now we can have is that has it
outlived its usefulness or do we need to
keep it going and reporters or is it
should be jettisoned or revitalized I
guess that's the process that began in
Rio and ended in Copenhagen is over okay
the top down un driven cap caps on
countries i do not think is going to be
revived i think what you're going to see
i think what the basic agreement points
us in the direction to is a much more
heterogeneous policy environment the
countries are going to take on with
different types of caps with intensity
calves with agreements on land use with
efficiency targets with some with hard
cap set cetera and with more types of
collaboration they'll be more
bilaterally in multilateral you can
obviously see the US and Mexico for
example coming in with some type of deal
to merge their carbon commitment going
forward or us and chili for example is
one that's been looted or the US or
Europe and Brazil and obviously the big
one is the US and China and that is
something that has embeds many more
things than than just simply climate
environmental concerns I think that what
Copenhagen showed is in part that the
climate issue is actually outgrown the
UN this is now the big boys playing this
is around big issues this is nationally
here's the executive branch talking to
each other on this that never happened
before and that is a very substantial
move and as such the UN frankly does not
rank above those people and that is
something you need Peterson where does
the UN go from here clearly Copenhagen
was a disaster was disaster both in
terms of its overall oh okay / disasters
slightly stronger it was a disaster in
terms of its overall outputs and what
was expected what came out and it was
not helped by the fact that it was
basically a logistical nightmare and
that you know put on to be put a lot of
pressure on people and there was no real
possibility to actually get people to
work on these things and that was
ultimately the problem where do we go
from here the UN can has to reestablish
its credibility as a neutral arbiter as
a more of a technical agency between
countries rather than just simply as I
say a top-down we shall do these things
collectively it needs to look if we're
going to have different types of
commitments how are we going to adjust
those against each other how is one
commitment going to look against another
how do you create some form of common
currency some sort of comparative pneus
to understand how things are working
between each other ultimately we do need
markets okay markets have to be part of
the solution I disagree a little booth
or not I don't I think that that policy
by definition shapes markets and puts
them in place and you have to have that
for this transitional phase we have an
enormous amount of capital stock out
there that will require change over not
every single power plant is going to be
able to put a a something on the back
end of it that will enable it to produce
viable materials with building for the
building stock okay we do need ways of
keeping what Kyoto showed us that
markets and innovation sprout up
everywhere as part of this process what
we need what I think I hear you sing at
and Peter I want to ask you to comment
on this is that we may be coming up with
it with
a heterogeneous patchwork of agreements
among nations a patchwork of policies
and that unless we have some sort of
very clear price signal that is so that
you have apples to apples to apples
despite this patchwork I mean the
problem with the patchwork is that you
could get a race to the bottom right I
can find ooh here's a loop hole through
which I can dive and what we're trying
to create as a race to the top we're
trying to create the incentives so that
you get a race at the top and and Peter
as you look at this post this future
first of all do you think that that's
right that we're going to have this this
this collection of bilateral
multilateral agreements and will that
give corporations like shell and you
know and other large corporations the
consistent global view that allows a
race to the top or do we run the risk of
a race to the bottom first of all as
shell we have always said we want market
solutions because that's in the longer
term what we will think will give us the
incentives to actually invest at the
lowest cost possible in order to
actually bring CEO to down to acceptable
levels simple boy we have also set we
cannot be a purist on this one that
everything works tomorrow it will know
it will just not happen that they are
having 45,000 people in Copenhagen
trying to sort something out it will
never work this way so i think i'm a
more pragmatic there and say we may
start off with bilateral multilateral
etc in order to get actually going and i
think we can handle that but i think in
the longer term if the market really
neat will function and neat and it needs
to function i think you will go towards
a more globalized market environment now
you can ask me the same question is this
one year is it 50 10 years do I care
most probably I'm in the camp of I don't
care that much at this stage I want to
get start to move but it needs to come
in an in the foreseeable future quite
clearly so I think I'm wait this basin
we have said I'm not entirely sure that
everything works in one year but then we
can come back to this family to me a
little bit later but I so therefore
market-based overall I think you will
have different countries doing it in
regions doing it differently at the
beginning I also think we need to part
from the UN process we need also the
industry's to start to work together you
need actually the coal industry to come
together how do you measure actually on
a worldwide basis for these based
practice don't quote I performance how
you want to drive that I've got my head
of refineries here we need to refine the
industry to come up with that we have
benchmark so I think we need to actually
that's what I meant we cannot wait until
you have a global framework we need to
take the initiatives the industry's
always work they do work best if they
have as an industry that actually the
challenge and we are normally quite good
in getting to the lowest cost solution
so I'm still convinced we will go on the
race to the top but I think it will be a
kind of a volatile bumpy road